- So, in the last several lectures,
we've been looking at the combined effects
of the disappearance of communism
as a viable alternative,
both in practice and in the imagination
of mainstream political thinking
as a serious economic alternative
to capitalism on the one hand,
and then on the other,
the effects of the declining
power of organized labor,
vis a vis capital,
in many of, if not all, of
the Western democracies.
And the effects of that
have been to enhance,
in one way or another, the prestige
of what was called neo-liberalism at home
and the Washington consensus abroad.
And we've seen how this played out,
particularly in the
agendas of privatization,
the increasing independence
of private money in politics
that we talked about last time,
and the erosion of what had been
the social democratic
consensus in Western Europe
and the great society
in the United States.
The next four lectures,
we're gonna refocus attention
back to the global order
and particularly the
idea that gained currency
in the first decades after the
collapse of the Soviet Union
and the end of the Cold War,
that there really was
gonna be a new global order
marked by the spread of democracy at home
and the, it was the spread
of democracy within countries
and the reshaping of global
international institutions.
And that's basically
what's gonna preoccupy us.
The first two lectures
are gonna be focused on
the spread of democracy or the expectation
that it was going to
spread around the world,
and then the next two are going to deal
with international institutions.
If there was going to be
a new, global, geopolitical order,
what form would people expect it to take?
I've called the lecture today
Democracy's Fourth Wave, question mark,
and I'm gonna focus
principally on South Africa
as a remarkable transition
with some comparisons
to the Middle East and Northern Ireland.
But I should say something
about this language of waves.
So, the idea of waves of democracy
came into currency, at least
in the academic literature,
in a book by Samuel Huntington
published in 1991 called "The Third Wave",
and it had, and I'll
talk a little bit more
about the waves in detail shortly,
but Huntington had argued that
a third wave of democratization
following the first two,
the first wave having
been the older democracies
that democratized very slowly
over the course of the 19th
and early 20th centuries,
the second wave being mostly the
democracies that emerged in
the era of decolonization,
of Africa and Asia after World War II,
and Huntington posited
that despite expectations
he, among others, had
written an article in
I think it was in the late
'70s, maybe in the early '80s
predicting that we wouldn't
see much more democracy.
By 1991, in "The Third Wave" he said,
well, we can really date this
new wave of democratization
to the Portuguese Revolution of 1974,
which led to democratizations
in the former Portuguese
colonies and elsewhere.
He had...
By the time he wrote that book,
he had also seen the democratizations
across Eastern Europe
which had largely occurred in 1989,
but the changes in the Soviet
Union lay in the future
and so he didn't have
anything to say about that.
And, indeed, he had very little to say
about the South African transition
that we're gonna focus on today,
which was also mostly in the future.
And the other books that
came out around that time,
such as Adam Przeworski's
"Democracy and the Market",
also were basically looking at this period
in the last part of the 20th century
from 1974 through
the redemocratization of Eastern Europe,
and they thought, "Is
this the third wave?"
Since the collapse of the Soviet Union
and some of the developments
we're gonna be talking about
over the next several lectures,
there's been a lot of
speculation about a fourth wave
that would incorporate some of the cases
like the South African transition,
the Arab Spring that
was much heralded in 2011 and 2012.
And we'll hold off assessing
whether or not we think
there's a fourth wave
is under way or likely
until we've gone through looking at
the conditions for the creation
and survival of democracy
and how we should think
about the various efforts,
some successful, some not,
at democratization in recent times.
So, the South African
transition to democracy
which occurs in the late
1980s and really starts
and goes through the
first election of 1994,
one thing to say about it was
a highly improbable outcome.
Nobody really expected it.
Indeed, if you go back to the 1970s,
which is when I started
out in political science,
it was a very common
observation to say that some of the
political conflicts in the
world were just so difficult
they were never gonna be solved.
They were, basically, sort of
the political basket cases of the world.
The conflicts were just
too entrenched, the
possibility of a successful
outcome too elusive,
and that we just have to sort
of come to grips with the fact
that there's some political
conflicts that can't be solved.
And the three exhibits that
were always wheeled out
to make this point were the conflict
between Protestants and
Catholics in Northern Ireland,
the Israel/Palestine conflict
which had been going on
in one form or another
since 1948 at least,
and South Africa,
the struggle between the apartheid regime
which had come to power in 1948
but had replaced a previous
government that had also
been heavily racist.
And many times, people said,
"Well, the South African conflict
"is the most intractable of intractables."
Partly because it was based on race
and racial exclusion is very difficult
to split the difference when you're...
One of the terms we use in
talking about identity politics
is that identity politics tends to involve
indivisible goods, not divisible goods.
If you think back to
our earlier discussion
of the divide a dollar game,
that presumes that you're dealing
with a divisible good, right?
So, you can divide it up in
different ways and you can get,
therefore, you can form different
coalitions and so forth.
When you're dealing
with indivisible goods,
those options are unavailable.
So, we had an indivisible
good, namely race,
and then we had a small, white minority,
less than 20% of the
population, considerably less,
and they were in power
and had no, they were in control
of the most powerful military
in South Africa, in Africa
until the prospect of a
transition became real,
they were widely known
to have nuclear weapons,
which they eventually gave up,
and it didn't seem like they
would give up with a fight,
without a fight and go anywhere.
And so most people,
even people who thought
the system was unstable,
which many people did,
thought that it would be
much more likely to end
in a civil war or a bloodbath.
And, of course, it was also
wired into the Cold War
because it was seen as
staunchly anti-communist and so
supported by many Western
governments in the 1980s.
And, indeed, in the US
there was a huge fight
over sanctions against South Africa
during the Reagan administration
when the Democrats controlled
Congress, as you now know,
and eventually the sanctions were passed
over Ronald Reagan's veto
in the mid-1980s, which is
a difficult thing to do.
You need two-thirds in both houses.
So, you can see, by the 1980s,
the support for the South African regime
was certainly hemorrhaging
in the advanced democracies,
but, nonetheless, they were
wired into the Cold War
until the end of it
and so didn't come under great pressure
from Western governments,
certainly not the US government.
So, when I left South Africa in 1972,
I didn't believe I would ever go back.
I thought that the possibilities
for a white, young, white person
of my, I was 15 years old,
the possibilities for making a life there
were virtually non-existent.
By that time, once you had turned 16,
they would not give you a passport
if you hadn't been to the military,
and by that time,
military service increasingly
was not sitting around in the desert
being ordered about by a lance corporal
but doing crowd control
in places like Soweto,
and I decided it was not for me.
And I really did...
And my beliefs were not unusual.
The vast majority of people
in the 1970s would have said
this conflict is gonna get
worse before it gets even worse,
(students laugh)
and the outcome is not,
certainly a good outcome was not in view.
And so, the world was shocked
on the second of February in 1990,
when Americans turned on the evening news
and this is what they heard.
- [Announcer] Sitting in
tonight, Diane Sawyer.
- Good evening.
They were bold words,
words that millions of people
had waited years to hear.
Today, in a 45-minute
State of the Nation speech,
President F.W. de Klerk
transformed 30 years
of South African politics.
He declared the African National Congress,
the major black opposition
group in South Africa,
to be legal.
He promised that its most famous leader,
Nelson Mandela, would soon be free.
Our first report is from ABC's
Richard Sergay in Cape Town.
(crowd singing joyfully)
- [Richard] Nearly 5000 people
who gathered near Parliament
to protest against Apartheid
today wound up celebrating.
- It's like a dream
come true, that's true.
- It's a big step forward,
a big step forward.
(brass band playing)
- [Richard] Opening his first
parliamentary session as president,
de Klerk made one thing clear right away.
The government is ready
to begin negotiating
South Africa's future
with the black majority.
- The season of violence is over.
The time for reconstruction
and reconciliation has arrived.
- [Richard] de Klerk told his colleagues
he was implementing a
series of immediate reforms,
partially lifting the state of emergency,
suspending executions,
and easing restrictions on
internal opposition groups.
Then came the biggest change in policy.
- The prohibition of the
African National Congress
is being rescinded.
(crowd cheers)
- [Richard] For the
first time in 30 years,
the white government's
sworn enemy, the ANC,
will be allowed to operate
openly in South Africa.
It wasn't until the end of his speech
that de Klerk finally mentioned the name
everyone was waiting to
hear, Nelson Mandela.
- That the government
has taken a firm decision
to release Mr. Mandela unconditionally.
I am serious about bringing this matter
to finality without delay.
- [Richard] But de Klerk says
Mandela won't be released
until what the president called
his personal circumstances
and safety are worked out.
de Klerk has met nearly all the conditions
that Mandela had set for leaving prison.
- I believe that we have
to give Mr. de Klerk
very, very considerable credit,
and we may be seeing
history in the making.
- [Richard] But leaders of
the African National Congress
in exile were more cautious.
- Quite clearly, an important
step forward has been made.
But perhaps it's half of a step.
- [Richard] Still,
President de Klerk's speech
confirmed the worst fears
of white conservatives.
- We were fighting with
everything we have to retain
the right of self-determination
of the white people
and to secure that there
will be no domination
of black people over whites.
- [Richard] Growing
pressure here and abroad
for real change left de Klerk
with very little choice.
Today, he challenged
critics on both sides.
"Walk through the open door," he said.
"Take your place at
the negotiating table."
Richard Sergay, ABC News, Cape Town.
- So, that was an
astonishingly dramatic moment.
It's hard to overstate, as I said,
how much it surprised many
people across the world.
And not only that.
Everything that de Klerk
said, he followed through on.
In early...
Early in that year,
they unbanned all illegal
political organizations,
they released all political prisoners,
including Mandela from his prison,
and legalized all political organizations,
many of which had been banned.
They then, over the course
of the next three years,
negotiated a settlement and
voluntarily gave up power,
and since that time, we've had
elections in '94, '99, 2004,
2009, 2014, and 2019
which have been judged by
independent organizations
to be genuine elections,
free and fair elections,
not rigged elections.
It is true that the
South Africa has not passed
what political scientists
sometimes refer to as
the two turnover test.
The political scientists
don't like to call a country a democracy
until it's happened twice
that a government has lost an election
and actually given up power.
'Cause you don't know what they'll do
if they lose an election,
and we don't know what the ANC would do
if it lost an election.
So, in that sense, it's not a consolidated
or an established democracy,
but there are some pretty reasonable signs
in a sense that, first of all,
we have had turnover in the leadership.
We haven't had a sort of situation
as with Mugabe in Zimbabwe where
he staggered on for decades
until he was finally dragged out of there.
Instead, we've had
hard-fought but nonetheless
successful transitions
after Mandela stepped down after one term.
Some people say his most important,
the most important decision
of his premiership because it
was a norm-setting
that people don't stay indefinitely.
Followed by our provost yesterday.
Then we had transition
to Mbeki, to Zuma,
and then a very hard-fought transition
to Cyril Ramaphosa more recently,
but we have seen people giving up power
in the leadership of the ANC.
And then it's also the case that the ANC
has become accustomed to losing elections
and giving up some power
because in addition to Cape Town,
which is controlled by the opposition
Democratic Alliance for a long time,
they have in
more recent elections,
they have lost control of
the other major cities,
Port Elizabeth, Pretoria, and Johannesburg
to opposition parties.
And so...
And local politics is not
unimportant in South Africa,
and so the notion that
when you lose an election
you actually give up power,
while it's not been embedded
at the level of the national government
has some traction in the
South African experience.
There are many problems with corruption
in South African politics,
much of which will concern us,
or the causes of it will concern us
on next Tuesday,
but by the standards of the
evaluation of most democracies,
South Africa looks pretty good.
They have the other indicators
you might be concerned about.
They have a relatively free
press, freedom of association,
an operating legal system, and so on.
And so certainly by the standards
of many new democracies,
it's been quite a remarkable story.
So, today's agenda is
we're gonna talk first
a little bit about getting
and keeping democracy,
what's required to get democracy,
what's required to keep it.
This will involve revisiting
some of the themes of modernization theory
that I talked about earlier
when we were talking about China.
Then I'm gonna talk about
transitions to democracy,
and I'm gonna separate out
four types of transition
and say something about them.
Then we're gonna zero in
on one of those four types,
which are negotiated settlements
of the sort that we
witnessed in South Africa
during the 1990s,
and that will lead us to some
evaluation of success,
failure, and inconclusiveness
by looking at that transition
in contrast with the continuous
failure after failure
in the Israel/Palestine conflict
and the more inconclusive
results in Northern Ireland.
Okay, so getting and keeping democracy.
There's some historical context to this,
some of which I have alluded to.
Huntington coined the phrase three waves,
and the first wave begins in
the late 18th century, really,
with the American Revolution
and the French Revolution
and it extends to the early 20th century
with the enfranchisement
of women in most countries,
except Switzerland when it didn't come
for another half century
and the enfranchisement, the reducing the
voting age often from 21 to 18,
which came in many
countries during the 1960s.
So, it was a very gradual
and long transition.
And that's not really surprising,
if you think about it,
because elites were afraid of democracy
for reasons we've already talked about.
They had some intuitive
grasp of the logic behind
the median voter theorem,
although they didn't use that terminology,
but they were worried.
They were worried
that if they suddenly
enfranchised the whole population,
it would threaten their
position and their property.
And so, for instance, in Britain,
we got significant expansion
of the franchised in 1832,
more in 1867,
more in 1885,
women in the 1920s,
and young people,
18 year olds, in the 1960s.
So, it's a sort of
some baby steps before big steps.
In the European countries it
happened a little more rapidly.
A lot of enfranchisement in
countries like Germany in 1870,
but still, we see a gradual
process of evolution,
if you like, toward democracy
rather than universal franchise.
And that is one thing that
differentiates the first wave
from the second wave
because the second wave is really
bound up with anti-colonial
struggles against Britain,
particularly, in Africa and Asia
but also against the
other colonial powers,
and those were countries that went from
very restricted or no franchise
to universal franchise
more or less overnight.
So, it is was a very different
kind of set of transitions,
and they had,
they happened much faster for that reason.
And then the third wave,
as I said to you already,
is retrospectively dated by Huntington,
somewhat arbitrarily one might say,
to the Portuguese Revolution in 1974
and what subsequently followed
in Eastern Europe, in
particular, in the late 1980s.
Now,
this creates this talk
about waves of democracy
and getting more and more democracies.
And indeed by the turn of the 21st century
we had more democracies in the world
than more non-democracies
for the first time in human history,
even if it was the case that more people
lived in non-democracies
than in democracies
because some of the non-democracies
have huge populations,
but, nonetheless, it creates
a kind of air of teleology
that informed the idea of
the end of history that
we've already talked about,
this idea that the world is steadily
becoming more democratic
and it just would be a matter of time
before these waves would come along,
and eventually the whole
world would be democratic.
That was never...
That was never a very good bet.
So, if you think about the three waves,
each one of those waves has
had significant undertow.
So, if we think about the first wave,
yes, we had the revolution
in France in 1789.
By 1791, it had turned into the terror
and something which nobody would think
was recognizably a democracy.
In Europe, in 1830,
across the continent we
had democratic revolutions
in just about every country except the UK,
which had led Marx and Engels
to think this was the beginning
and the end of capitalism.
And even in the UK we had
the Chartist movement,
which people were terrified
might turn into a revolutionary movement
or hopeful that it might turn
into a revolutionary movement
depending on your point of view.
By 1832, those revolutions had collapsed
and the monarchies had all been restored
across the continent.
The same thing happened in 1848.
Again, democratic
revolutions swept Europe and
by 1849, 1850, they
pretty much all collapsed,
and the non-democracies were back.
If we think about the 20th century
up through the end of the first wave,
of course we had the advent
of fascism, of Nazism
in Italy and in Germany,
and in the US, massive
retrenchment after the Civil War
of democratic rights
through the Jim Crow period,
huge disenfranchisement.
I talked about the Supreme Court's reading
of the Civil War amendments last time
to restrict their application
and particularly to
restrict the application
of the 15th amendment,
where you couldn't exclude
people on the basis of race
but you could find surrogates
like literacy tests
and poll taxes and so forth.
So, there was lots of undertow
to the first wave of democratization.
It's not like you get these things
and then you can't ratchet back.
If you think about the second wave,
again, many, many democracies
that were established,
when the British left,
the first election turned
out to be the last election.
Lots of theorizing and literature
and speculation about why that is the case
or why that was the case.
Perhaps one of the most
plausible accounts is that
where the British governed
by direct rule, as in India,
democracy got better traction
because you had whole
generations of Indian elites
who went to Oxford and Cambridge
and came back and
embedded democratic norms
and values in their institutions
before the British left,
whereas in South Africa,
and much of the rest of Africa,
the British governed indirectly,
which essentially was much cheaper
because you didn't have
to set up your own whole,
your whole bureaucracy and civil service
and institutional capacity
and instead found local chiefs
or sometimes more or
less created local chiefs
and said, "Provided you
deliver what we want,
"you can govern as you please."
And so there was much more
indirect rule in Africa,
unlike the direct rule in India,
so some people put it down to that.
Wonderful book on this subject
by a man called Mahmood Mamdani,
who's a professor of political science
and anthropology at Columbia,
called "Citizen and Subject",
about the legacy of direct
versus indirect rule.
There are other theories,
and it's not an unproblematic
theory itself because,
after all, Pakistan had the
same direct rule as India
and didn't have such a happy,
democratic future as India did.
So, it's a complex story,
but, nonetheless, there
was plenty of undertow.
Many, many democracies
that had been created,
as the imperial powers left,
turned out not to survive.
And then, if we think
about the third wave,
again, there's also been
significant undertow there.
We've seen,
I probably should've put
Pakistan on the second wave,
but much of Latin America.
We've seen, we saw
collapses of democracy in
various countries or at least
serious compromising of it
in Burma, in Fiji, where
coups seem to come and go,
Algeria in 1991 we had a coup,
and of course the ongoing
questions about Russian democracy
that have become more acute with time.
So, the idea that
there's some inevitablism
that democracy's just once you
get it, you keep it forever,
clearly not true.
Democracies can fall apart
and sometimes they do.
And so that puts on the table the question
so what are the conditions
for democracy to arrive
and what are the conditions
for democracy to survive?
And that provokes some
theoretical questions,
and there's a huge theoretical literature
in political science.
I underlined the science because
political science aspires
to make predictions.
It aspires to tell us
what the conditions are
under which we are likely to get
a particular outcome.
And so, what can we predict?
And on democratization,
one distinction that
political scientists have made
that was not present in the
early modernization literature
that I was
talking about when we discussed China
is a distinction between
transitions to democracy
and the survival of democracy.
And, in particular,
Adam Przeworski and his
co-authors in this book,
published at the turn of the century,
said we should really think differently
about these two things,
and the reason is
that what produces
transitions to democracy
is probably inherently unpredictable.
It depends on so many
contingencies that have to line up
that you really can't, you can't predict
when it's going to happen.
On the other hand, you
can say something about,
however you get a democracy,
how likely is it to survive.
And so Przeworski
and others said we should really
separate out these two things
and stop talking about transitions.
And so he, his work and the
work of many other colleagues
represent pretty much a
conventional wisdom about survival.
So, if I, just to do a little polling here
before I tell you what they say,
if I said to you, have
we got the microphone?
What do you think is
most important to have
for a democracy to survive?
Anyone. (mumbles)
- [Student] An educated population.
- An educated population
is one possibility, others.
- A strong judicial system.
- Strong judicial system.
- A healthy economy.
- Healthy economy.
Couple more here.
- [Student] I would say that
all actors in the economy
or in the political system believe
they can win more from the system
than from trying to overthrow it.
- Okay, yep.
- A middle class.
Barrington Moore supporter
over there, yeah.
So, okay, so,
it is the economy, stupid,
as Clinton is famous for saying.
People used to think political
culture mattered a lot
or that certain kinds of religions
were more or less
compatible with democracy,
but if you look at the data,
none of those things
is much of a predictor.
And so, here are the main things
that people say are important
for a democracy to survive.
One is per capita income of about 14,000
2019 dollars,
that if you...
This is Przeworski and his...
I've converted it into more
2019 dollars, but basically,
their data set,
which is through the last century
not the current one, shows
that if a country has, if a
country is already a democracy
and has per capita income
of that amount or higher,
its democracy survives indefinitely,
and if it falls below that,
it becomes more fragile
and the further below that it falls,
the more fragile it becomes.
Notice that doesn't say
anything about inequality.
Because you can have a
very high per capita income
in a very unequal country.
So, there's per capita income,
then a second is the
diversification of the economy.
This is the whole oil curse literature.
We talked about this somewhat
in relation to Hirschman,
"Exit, Voice, and Loyalty",
that if the whole economy
is dominated by one sector
that's controlled by the government,
which is usually the case if
it's an oil curse economy,
people will very, be very
reluctant to give up power
if it's the only access to
advancement and success,
and they'll be very prone
to grab power if they can
if it's the only access to,
provides the only access
to advancement and success.
And so when Al Gore didn't
become president in 2000
in a knife-edge election which he,
many people thought he'd actually won,
he wasn't happy.
Nonetheless, he could
go on corporate boards,
go around the world making
movies about climate change,
and I saw his net worth
is 250 million dollars.
It's not so bad for him.
(students laughing)
Not so bad for Al.
It wouldn't be the case if he
lived in an oil curse country.
Now, some people would
say and some people say
oil curse is, generally
speaking, bad for democracy.
And notice that the countries
that have discovered oil
after they've been diversified,
like Norway or Scotland,
don't have this problem.
So, it's the diversification
which creates multiple opportunities
for people to advance in the world
other than grabbing the
commanding heights of the state.
It was important, by the way,
in the early American republic
that when the capitol was,
whether it was in New York,
Philadelphia, or Washington,
these were not places
the elites wanted to be.
They wanted to be out
making money in Virginia,
on their farms,
and so the desire to hold onto power
was not particularly strong.
It wasn't that valuable to them.
And Washington had to be
persuaded to run again.
So did Jefferson
have to be persuaded to
run for a second term.
That's the kind of thing that
highlights the fact
that political power wasn't that valuable.
Alternation in power.
I talked about the two
turnover test already.
So, this is the notion
that if you give up power,
you're more likely to give
up power in the future.
Alternation predicts alternation,
coups predict coups, right?
So...
India maybe got lucky,
whereas Pakistan didn't
and so then you get...
There's a big, big...
This is, again, a paper by Adam Przeworski
saying if you get one or two turnovers,
and certainly if you get three turnovers,
they go on forever.
Now, what's the causal
story here is another matter
because it may be the conditions
that lead to people being given up,
being willing to give
up power once remain.
And so it's not the alternation
that's predicting the giving
up power but the conditions,
like a diversified economy,
that's actually making them
to keep giving up power
into the future.
Nonetheless, countries that
have histories of alternation
tend to alternate,
and countries where
there's a history of the military
jumping into politics
when they're not happy,
they tend to do it.
Another consideration I
will just put out there
'cause it's been a theme
in the course so far
and it will be more of
a theme in the future
is my intuition, I haven't done
systematic research on this,
but that,
that downward mobility and loss aversion
are more important than
people give credit for.
So, if you look at some of the countries
in which democracy has become fragile,
often it's not the poor
and it's not people
complaining about inequality,
but it's downwardly mobile people,
middle class people in Cairo
who find their prices
going up, for example,
and one could give many other examples.
It can be middle class disaffection
when people start to experience or expect
that they're going to
experience downward mobility.
But the takeaway is this is
largely an interest-based story.
It's not so much norms
or culture, it seems,
but more, more interest-based.
Though, as I said, disentangling
some of the causation
between the interests and the norms,
like the norms of giving up power,
can be very tricky to do empirically.
Let's, though, talk about transitions.
Przeworski said it's a mug's game
trying to predict transitions.
Too much contingency in there.
And, indeed, after 1989
he wrote a piece saying
now we're gonna see
hundreds of trees get wasted
by people coming up with
theories of transitions,
and at the end of the day,
they're not gonna be worth a hill of beans
because there's too much contingency.
Actually, it didn't stop Przeworski
from coming up with his
own theory of transitions,
but be that as it may,
I wanna say not so fast.
And that while it's true we
can't predict transitions,
we can learn some interesting things
about the conditions that are necessary
for them to be successful,
and that's what I'm gonna
be talking about next.
So, what I wanna do first
of all is single out
some different kinds of
transitions from one another.
They're basically four ways
to get from non-democracy to a democracy.
One is intervention from outside.
A country goes in and installs
democracy somewhere else.
And the two famous success
stories here, of course,
are West Germany and
Japan after World War II,
and so the notion that you
can't install democracy by force
is obviously false, at least
as a categorical statement.
Now, there are many,
many reasons that people give
about why those installations
of democracy were successful,
ranging from the fact that
they both had histories
of democracy in the inter-war period
to the fact that the Allies
stayed there for decades,
that they invested in the
Marshall Plan in Germany
and economic resuscitation
of the Japanese economy
to the Cold War and the creation of NATO.
But for whatever reason,
there have been external
installations of democracy.
We've seen attempts at that
in countries like Afghanistan and Iraq
that we'll have more to say about later,
where the answer's not so much.
Perhaps 'cause all of those
conditions were missing
or perhaps for other reasons.
We'll be digging into that later.
The second way in which you get democracy
is by a revolution from
below, democratic revolution.
People are opposed to autocracy.
They get together, have a revolution,
and create a democracy.
Some success stories there,
of course, the American Revolution.
People tend not to talk about the US
when they do comparative policy,
but the US is one case in the world
and the American
Revolution was a successful
revolution from below.
It was of an elite below
in that was an anti-colonial
revolution run by an elite.
Nonetheless, it was a
revolution from below.
The Portuguese Revolution,
to a large extent,
was a revolution from below.
Of all the 1989 transitions,
the one that comes closest
to a revolution from below
was the Romanian transition where
the Ceausescus were just pretty
much wheeled out of a court
and shot behind a,
behind a barn.
One might say that had the Mensheviks
been more stronger than the Bolsheviks,
Russia might have had a
democratic revolution in 1917.
The Mensheviks were democrats
and might have had a
very different history,
and it turned out, of
course, they were not.
The Libyan civil war, ongoing civil war
started out with an expectation
on the part of NATO and the Western powers
that it was gonna be, lead
to a democratic transition.
Again, not so much.
Another subject we're gonna revisit.
Now, a third path to democracy
is when the elites in
power decide to give it up.
The military decides to leave power
for reasons that,
again, people debate.
Or even in a non-military
regime, an authoritarian regime,
the leadership decides to give up power.
This happens when Juan Carlos
decided to give up power in Spain.
It happened in Brazil.
Of course, there was pressure from below.
It's not, these...
Another of way of putting it,
these are sort of ideal types.
Many transitions are hybrids,
to some extent, of them,
so I wouldn't wanna say they
all fit in one of these boxes
but the center of gravity is elite
willingness to give up power.
Would you look at what happened in Egypt
in the beginning of the Arab Spring?
The military got strongly
behind the transition,
for reasons that are
very well described, I think, by,
in the book "Thieves of State" by,
who wrote "Thieves of State", somebody?
Sarah Chayes.
They got, very much got
behind the initial revolution,
but of course, they came
roaring back into power
a year and a half later.
So, again, not so successful there.
And then, this is...
As I said, political
scientists are not famous
for elegant terminology.
This is Huntington's term, transplacement,
and the only reason I use that
is Przeworski's term is even less elegant.
He calls it extrication.
It's like going to the dentist.
So, what is, how do you get democracy
by going to the dentist?
This is a negotiated settlement,
a negotiated transition
from authoritarianism to democracy.
And this is, South
Africa's a classic case.
Of the East European ones,
the closest to that was
the Polish transition,
which really starts long before 1989.
It starts in the early 1980s
where the Solidarity
movement emerges in Gdansk
and the regime finds it's necessary
to make various concessions to them.
And it's almost a decade-long
negotiation in Poland
which culminates in 1989,
but it's basically a
negotiated settlement.
Israel/Palestine and Northern
Ireland, again, not so much.
So, again, you can see that they're
outside, and from inside
above, below, and negotiated.
That sort of exhausts the
universe of possibilities.
Now, most of the interest
has been in this last
category, among academics,
and I think that the reason for that
is probably the reason, partly
the reason Przeworski gives,
that if you think about the other three,
the extent to which they really depend
on contingencies is very high.
When will...
Predicting when it'll be the
case that an invading country
will be willing to make
the kind of investments
that the US made in Germany and Japan
after World War II seems,
it seems like a very
difficult proposition.
Or predicting, if you
do have a revolution,
whether there'll be divisions
among the opposition groups.
Predicting, if...
As I said, if the Mensheviks
had been stronger,
maybe they would have won.
There were democratic, there
were more democratic forces
in the French Revolution that lost out.
They were less...
There were people that wanted to restore
some sort of monarchy after
the American Revolution.
They lost out.
But, again, this seems
like contingencies that
you're very unlikely to be able to come up
with any generalizations about.
Similarly, with elites deciding
to transform things from above,
it's probably gonna depend on
unpredictable conflicts among
military or political elites,
the alternatives that they
have available to them,
and other things that are gonna be,
from the point of view of coming up
with any kind of
serviceable generalizations,
accidents of history.
So, there is literature,
but by far the most attention
has been focused on these transplacements.
And I think one is that
people have thought,
actually, they do lend themselves
to the tools of social science,
even if not predictive tools
in the sense of point predictions,
that you can use, among other things,
the term, the insights from
game theory and you can predict
at least what makes them
more likely to succeed
or less likely to succeed.
And then I...
This was just my observation.
It could be wrong,
but I think the other reason
there's so much attention
to negotiated settlements is
that it seems normatively good.
Democratic paths to democracy
seem like a great thing,
that we don't have to
kill thousands of people,
perhaps hundreds of thousands of people.
We can find a way to do it peacefully.
And so I think the fact that,
that this seems to have
desirable, normative properties
makes people want to understand
what are the conditions
under which you're likely to get
a negotiated settlement to democracy.
So, what are the conditions?
And I'm gonna give you a
sort of stylized picture
of these kinds of conflicts
and how they tend to get
resolved when they do.
And we can think about it
as the governing elite,
government on the one side
and then the opposition movement,
not a political opposition party
because probably the opposition is banned,
but there's a government and an opposition
but they're not monolithic.
They're not monolithic.
They're divided into at least two groups.
And so, you could think
of the standpatters
or reactionaries who are gonna
fight all change at all times
and then reformers who are
at least open to change,
on the government side.
And then on the opposition side,
you could think about a division,
a mirror image division
into moderates and radicals.
This is not moderates and
reformers about policy,
but moderates being people
who would, in principle,
be open to a negotiated settlement,
whereas the radicals think,
"No, we've gotta have a revolution.
"We've gotta take over
and we've gotta impose
"a new dispensation on the country."
And what creates the possibility
of a negotiated settlement
is a circumstance in which
reformers and moderates,
individually, are not powerful
enough to force change
but if they could get
together, they would be.
Right, if they could get
together and form an alliance,
they would be.
And so, then, the 64 million
dollar question becomes
well, what are the conditions
that make that
possible or likely?
And it's not easy.
The first thing to say is it's not easy.
At least three things have to happen.
One is the reformers and
moderates have to agree,
and if you think of a condition
of a decades-long civil war where
many people have friends and families
who have been killed in this war,
very high stakes politics, lots of hatred,
lots of resentment and anger,
it's not obvious that the reformers
and moderates are going
to be able to agree,
even if there are groups
that might be open to change.
A second requirement is that
the standpatters and radicals
have to be convinced,
co-opted, or marginalized.
If none of the above,
they will throw a wrench
into the whole process
and stop it, right?
Inevitably.
Or they certainly will try.
So, unless they can be convinced,
co-opted, or marginalized,
they're probably gonna blow
it up before it's done.
And then the third is that
you have to build support
for the new dispensation because
these groups have grassroots supporters,
but they're not grassroots
supporters for this.
They might potentially be,
but they're not gonna drop out of the sky.
If you're gonna have a
negotiated settlement,
people are gonna have
to build support for it.
So, those three things have to happen,
and they have to happen at the right time.
And we'll see what happens
when they don't happen
at the right time shortly.
Okay, so that's a lot, right?
It's a big menu.
And this means there's a,
for a negotiated settlement,
there's a kind of threading
the needle quality
to the whole thing.
And so when we think about the conditions
for successful negotiations,
one of them is obviously luck, right?
You need luck.
And this is
what we're gonna, what
Przeworski was pointing at
when he said you can't
generalize about this.
And I'm gonna use three
word, three things you need.
You need luck, you need leadership,
and you need legitimacy.
The reason you need luck is
there's so many more ways
for them to fail than to succeed.
So many things have to line up
in the right way at the right time
in order to get a successful
negotiated settlement.
People often talk about the
importance of leadership
without defining it.
I'm gonna mean three things by leadership.
One is people with an
unusual appetite for risk.
Most politicians are
pretty risk-averse.
They mostly wanna
keep what they've got, get re-elected,
and stay out of trouble.
Politicians who have
the leadership qualities
that are gonna be required
have to have an appetite for risk,
but it's not just any old risk.
They...
Gambling is risk-taking but it's reckless.
You don't want reckless risk-taking.
You want people that have
good strategic judgment
about what are the
risks that must be taken
and how must they be taken?
And to what end?
And in particular,
you're gonna need people
who are willing to take big personal risks
for a cause that's larger than
their own personal interest
and then to have the
good strategic judgment
to know what is a good calculated risk
and what is a reckless move
that is not likely to succeed.
And the third essential element
of good leadership is empathy.
Now, empathy is not sympathy, right?
Sympathy is feeling sorry for people.
Empathy is understanding what people need.
It's seeing the world
from the point of view
of the person you're dealing with.
Because if you don't
understand what they need,
you will not have a successful
negotiation with them.
So, those are the three
important elements of
effective leadership.
Now, when I say legitimacy,
I'm alluding here to the debate about
democratization from above and from below.
And so the story here is that
some people say, "Oh, it's not legitimate
"if it doesn't come from below.
"The people have to validate it."
Others say, "No, it's
all about elite pacts,"
elites making deals with one another.
The short answer is that it is both,
and the reason is
that democracy is a public
good in the economist sense.
It's a technical public good.
Supplying it to some means
supplying it to all, right?
It's not excluded and it's non-rivalrous
in that some people having democracy
doesn't exclude others
from having democracy.
So, it's a public good,
and it's notoriously difficult
to supply public goods democratically.
And so that means there will be moments
when elites have to take decisive action,
but if they can't build support
for the actions that they are taking,
then they're not going to be successful.
Yes, sir.
- [Student] Following the
dividing the dollar game
and what you mentioned of marginalizing,
couldn't you just marginalize elites
or marginalize the lower classes
and just build a good
enough coalition to go over?
- The problem there is who is you?
Okay, there's no you to do it.
So, they have to see it
as in their interest.
So, what I wanna do now is
work through the South African
and Middle East cases here
from the perspective of
these three considerations.
So, the luck in South Africa,
what was one thing that was very important
was a decaying status quo.
Whatever the future was gonna be,
South African elites understood
that it wasn't gonna be
the same as the past.
Partly because the new
generation of black youth
was much more militant than
its, than their parents.
They were burning down their schools,
they were refusing to study
in the Afrikaans textbooks,
and so on and so the costs
of repression were going up.
That meant the children
of the white elites
didn't want to join the army,
as I indicated the first
minute of this lecture,
and so the elites felt the
sand shifting under their feet.
That didn't mean you would get democracy,
but it meant that the
status quo was gonna change.
The bankruptcy that ensued in the 1980s
when Citibank refused to
roll over South Africa's debt
contributed as well.
Another factor, a contingent
factor that helped a lot
was the disappearance of
communism as a viable alternative,
which made whites much less
frightened of a transition
for reasons I'll talk about on Tuesday,
and for the ANC,
the Soviet Union stopped
funding them in 1983
because the Soviet Union was
going bankrupt in Afghanistan
and while it was fighting
Star Wars spending
with the Reagan administration.
And so the ANC was in this situation
of facing the most
powerful army in Africa and
didn't have the resources.
They went to the Chinese,
the Chinese said no,
and that produced a group within the ANC
that was willing to think about
talking about a negotiated settlement.
Leadership.
I wanna spend a little
bit of time on this.
So, I became very consumed
with the counterfactual.
Here we had the successful
negotiated transition
in South Africa
between Mandela and de
Klerk on the one hand,
and if you look at Israel/Palestine,
it had many structural
similarities but it had failed.
So, but for example, in the early 1990s,
there had been something
called the Oslo Accords.
People had...
There'd been a lot of
negotiating between the PLO
and the Israeli government,
and many people started to believe
that there was gonna be a
transition to a settlement.
And if you went there in 2004 or 2005,
people, most people thought
this is coming to a successful conclusion.
And, indeed, Arafat
moved somewhat to the middle.
He recognized Israel's right to exist.
He took some other of the
preconditions off the table
that had been so important,
and Yitzhak Rabin,
they seemed to be
converging on a settlement.
There was a lot of work had been done
to build support for
it in both communities.
People expected it.
Yet when Rabin was assassinated
by a right-wing Israeli,
it all fell apart.
Peres came into power.
He temporized, he moved to the right.
Arafat was phoning him three times a week
saying, "We've gotta get this done,"
because as he had moved to the middle,
that's when Hamas emerged on his flank
and seized all the symbols
of Palestinian nationalism.
And so he realized he had to get a deal.
Peres tacked to the right,
basically cut off the talks.
Netanyahu won an election
six months later anyway,
and the sort of window
of opportunity closed.
So, I got interested in
what would have happened if
Rabin hadn't been assassinated
and maybe if de Klerk had
been assassinated in 1992.
How would things have looked
differently today subsequently?
And so,
I went and interviewed
de Klerk about this,
and I asked him.
And I said, "What would've happened if you
"or Mandela had been assassinated
during this process?"
And the backstory here is that
as the negotiations had
been getting into trouble
and breaking down, violence
had been increasing in 1991
and early 1992,
and this showed up with
increasing white anxiety
which expressed itself
in the government losing by-elections.
They lost three big by-elections in a row.
And de Klerk came,
responded to this by going on
television one night one night
and saying, "I'm calling a referendum
"on whether I should
negotiate a settlement
"with the African National Congress."
So, that's the backstory here.
So, what he said was the following.
He said, "Well,
"if Mandela had been
assassinated in the late 1980s,
"it might have scuttled things because
"at that time he was having
secret talks with the government
"and it is not clear there was anyone
"willing to do that in the ANC."
And he, Mandela, had kept them secret
because he thought if they failed,
people could denounce him
as a doddering old man
and it wouldn't damage the ANC's cause.
That's what I mean.
A willingness to take risks
for a cause that's larger than yourself.
de Klerk said, "In my case,
"if I had been assassinated
after the referendum,"
which he won by a two-thirds majority,
he said, "it wouldn't really have mattered
"because whoever replaced
me would have gone on.
"But the reason I went on television
"and announced the referendum was
"that everyone in my cabinet
would have opposed it
"and everyone in the national
party would have opposed it.
"And so I just went in and
announced it as a fait accompli.
"And if you think of,
"if you think of a circumstance in which
"I had been shot before I
had called the referendum,
"there wouldn't have been
anyone in a position to do it.
"And even if they had wanted to do it,
"it's not something a new
president can do as their first,
"they have to build support
in the cabinet and so on."
So, then it might well have played out,
it might well have played out differently.
That was very important because
the fact that he won that referendum
and essentially took on the
far right in his own party
meant that
the ANC could convince the skeptics there
that he was serious,
that he was essentially burning bridges
with the far right of the
national party establishment
and making his future depend upon
getting a successful
negotiation with the ANC.
And so that was a level of risk-taking
that sometimes what solved what
political scientists called
the commitment problem.
He could...
Skeptics in the ANC could be persuaded
by Ramaphosa and Mandela,
who were for negotiations,
that this was a person
with whom they could work.
I've already, so that was one of the ways
in which he took on the opposition.
The other thing to say is that
it's very important to
build support from below.
If you look at,
fast-forward to 2000
when Bill Clinton is
about to leave office,
he decides, like many American
presidents before him,
that the last thing he's gonna do
is solve the Middle East conflict
on the way out in the summer of 2000,
and he brings
Arafat and the Israeli leader
who by that point was Barak.
He drags them to Washington and says,
"You need to make this deal
that wasn't made five years ago
"when Rabin was killed."
And they both say no.
And he tries to, he thinks...
Bill Clinton thought if he
just can get people in a room
and twist their arms
and look them in the eye
and tell them that they're the
most important in the world,
people in the world, he could get it done.
And the reason he couldn't get it done
was that there was no support
in either community in the summer of 2000.
The Palestinian support was below 10%
and the Israeli support was below 8%.
So, even though it was substantially
the same deal as five years
before, it didn't matter.
There was no support for it.
There were no constituencies for it,
and this is why below
matters as well as above.
And so all, The Economist was
writing about these articles.
What's wrong with the Palestinians?
They never miss an opportunity
to miss an opportunity,
and so on and so forth.
They didn't understand
that the dynamics on the
ground were different.
And so you have to have
the support from below.
Right, so, we can't predict transitions,
but we can say something
about what makes them
more and less likely.
For one thing, we can predict failure.
In 1983,
Gerry Adams became head
of Shin Fein, the IRA,
and people said, "Oh, this
is a new kind of politician.
"He wears business suits, he
talks like Western politician,
"maybe there can be a
settlement in Northern Ireland."
But, of course, in 1983,
you had a conservative
government in Westminster
that was crucially dependent
on the Northern Irish
for its parliamentary majority.
So, there was no question.
Far from the status quo
being a wasting asset,
the sand shifting under their feet,
there was no possibility that the Tories
would make a deal with the IRA.
1997, when Tony Blair comes in,
Labour's not dependent on
the Northern Irish vote
so then it becomes a possibility,
and eventually we get
the Good Friday Accords,
which semi-unravel later.
So, you can think usefully
about the conditions here.
What is it that's gonna move the elites,
and will they
think that they can't move?
Empathy and strategic
judgment, hugely important.
One thing de Klerk said to me
that I thought was very
interesting in that interview.
At the end of it, I said to him,
"What do you think explains the difference
"between the South African
"and the Israel/Palestine negotiations?"
And he said, "Well, one
important difference was
"that when we decided to legalize the ANC
"and the opposition movements,
we had no preconditions,
"and when the ANC, three months later,
"decided to suspend the armed struggle,
"there were no preconditions.
"We didn't ask them to
recognize our legitimacy.
"We wanted them to decommission
"but we didn't make it a
requirement, no preconditions."
Of course, there are
implicit preconditions,
in the sense that if you
don't deliver within a,
before the window of opportunity closes,
it'll all fall apart.
But he said, "The fact that we,
"there were no explicit
preconditions meant that
"we had more room to maneuver."
And, of course, it meant the spoilers
couldn't violate the preconditions.
If you say, "These talks will go on
"as long as there are no rockets,"
there will be rockets, right?
So, no pre...
That's empathy, it's understanding.
It's understanding what people need.
Mandela understood that
even though the ANC
was opposed to power-sharing
in the permanent constitution,
de Klerk had to get it in
the interim constitution
or there wouldn't have been a transition,
so he agreed to it and
later on it went away.
In April 1993,
a black radical
leader, Chris Hani, was murdered,
and the violence erupted
and it threatened to
engulf the whole process.
And one of the ways in
which it was tamped down
was that de Klerk agreed
that the election would occur
no later than a year after Hani's death.
So, it had to be by April 1994,
so a definite date that it had to occur,
and that enabled Mandela and
the ANC to quell the violence
and move things forward.
So, that's hugely important,
that you understand what
the other side needs
and make sure they can get what they need,
otherwise it's gonna fall apart.
Exit options, right?
People have to find it
possible to give up power.
In South Africa, they
promised an amnesty process.
They processed civil service
jobs, security for five years.
This hearkens back to
our earlier discussion
of the Soviet Union, that
the exit costs were lower
because of the way privatization occurred.
And when we think about the
demonstration effects here
of the ways in which
Gaddafi and Mubarak met
their end, their fates,
it doesn't all go well
because the leaders in
other countries that might be
facing opposition movements
think about what'll happen
to them if they leave.
So, good things don't always go together.
Let's give de Klerk the last word
before we head out.
- I think it was an absolute necessity
that he had to be released.
As his image grew over the years,
as he became
an icon, as he became
a crucial flashpoint
in the whole international
situation also of South Africa,
it became clear to me that,
that he has a pivotal role to play
and that he was playing it,
irrespective of the fact
that he was in jail.
He was leaner than I thought,
he was taller than I thought,
and my very first impression
was that he was a very dignified man.
We were both reserved,
but there was immediately
a sort of a good,
good spark between us.
He had a few habits.
Firstly, he was a very good listener.
He would rarely or almost
never interrupt one
when one was making a point.
On the other hand,
he got highly irritated
if he was interrupt.
I was scoring points in the debate.
He leveled the score by,
fairly near to the end but
before we reached the end,
suddenly reaching out and taking my hand.
- I am proud to hold your hand,
for us to go forward together.
(audience applauding)
- It was a masterpiece,
that taking my hand.
He's good at it.
Ah, I took his hand,
nothing I could do about it.
And lifted quietly my,
in my mind, my hat to him
and said, "Well done."
- Okay, we'll see you on Tuesday.
(bright ascending notes)